you to our top story tonight A man is
dead after an attempted robbery turned
officer involved shooting this happened
in North Las Vegas last night near
Decatur and Grand Teton that's where we
find Madison Kimbrough with the latest
in this investigation Madison
known to most as a quite gated community
here in North Las Vegas many stayed
indoors on Saturday night in fear of
what was going on across their driveway
it was a chaotic night Saturday as North
Las Vegas Police Department responded to
a call about an unknown man who was
possibly drunk or high trying to break
into a house using a long metal pole
when officers arrived at about 10 17 PM
they located the man he was armed with a
rifle
at about 10 30 p.m officers reported
that shots had been fired North Las
Vegas Police say the suspect was shot at
least once and was taken to UMC where he
later died neighbors say the shooting
started with what looked like a party at
this house in their gated North Las
Vegas Community they had guest service
there's a few cars out front and all so
it looked like it might have been a
party or something like that going on
minutes later or so had my headset on
and I heard pop pop pop
and uh my daughter came and said hey did
you hear them like yeah I think I heard
it too went out in the back came out
front and that's when I saw law
enforcement Ken Allen who lives across
the street says the man involved in the
shooting was no stranger to the
neighborhood as he was a resident
himself Alan recalling a time where he
and his family interacted with them mail
have been delivered to uh our mailbox by
mistake came over met him briefly hey
you know here's your mail I know that my
wife and his wife they had spoken
numerous times as they've worked
together a couple times times
and so far the suspect and officer have
not been identified in the shooting
reporting in North Las Vegas tonight
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now